hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm learning more about article
seven of the US Constitution which is
the provision that specified the
conditions for the Constitution to
become law it reads the ratification of
the conventions of nine States shall be
sufficient for the establishment of this
constitution between the states so
ratifying the same although this sounds
simple it reminds us that when the
framers finished drafting the
Constitution in Philadelphia in 1787 it
was by no means a done deal at least
nine states had to ratify the
Constitution in order to replace the
existing government under the Articles
of Confederation to learn more about the
ratification process I sought out the
help of two experts mark Graber is the
Jacob a France professor of
constitutionalism at the University of
Maryland Frances King Carey School of
Law Michael Rapaport is the darling
foundation professor at the University
of San Diego School of Law professor
Graber can you tell us a little bit
about the political context of
ratification what was going on at this
time as the framers tried to put a new
constitution into the fabric of the
United States
well one central problem of the Articles
of Confederation was the Articles
required that all 13 states consent for
any amendment and it turned out at this
time Rhode Island was a great outlier so
Rhode Island wasn't going to consent to
much of anything and in fact Rhode
Island did not even send delegates to
the convention that drafted the
Constitution so the framers knew that if
you had the unanimous rule for
ratification it would not work so
instead they chose nine it's about
two-thirds three-fourths in part to make
sure Rhode Island and one outlier could
not prevent adoption so let's remember
there's two stages here and how the
Constitution gets written and ratified
so first it's written in what's called
the drafting convention or the
Philadelphia Convention which was held
during the summer of 1787 and in that
convention there was pretty much an
agreeing
that the federal government needed to be
made stronger but that was just a
proposal in order for the Constitution
to be ratified it needed nine of the 13
states and so we went to the second
stage and there things were and in some
ways going to be more difficult because
there was a variety of viewpoints in the
different states and the main question
that came up in state after state after
state was was the federal government
being given too much additional power
under the previous regime of the
Articles of Confederation the federal
government had very limited powers and
the Constitution was going to give the
federal government more power they
wanted a strategy that once the ball
started rolling states that was slower
we're going to be faced with a choice
you could get in on the inside and maybe
effect some changes early but if you
were left out whatever happened would
happen without you and a lot of states
at the end were fearful of what being
left out this strategy worked and as
they went through in tough states as
time went on so New Hampshire Virginia
New York North Carolina Rhode Island in
order to get ratification each time they
promised will will have a bill of rights
and those states added a list of
amendments that they wanted added to the
Constitution so was it controversial
that the framers decided that only nine
states would be necessary to ratify the
Constitution very controversial one of
these central points of anti-federalists
was that this was illegal that the
existing Constitution said all states
and therefore only all states could
change the Constitution so in that
respect it was somewhat controversial
another way in which it departed from
the Articles so the article said you
needed the state legislatures to approve
the amendments and the US Constitution
said no we want state conventions
special bodies elected by the people to
approve these things
why did they say that because they
feared that the state legislators who
would be losing a lot of power under the
Constitution would vote against it so
they wanted sort of to go directly to
the people in these conventions and
bypass the state legislatures so we know
that there were some opponents of this
new constitution how close did they
actually come to preventing its
ratification well it was a very close
fight we look back on it and eventually
all 13 states were gonna ratify and it
just looks like oh well that wasn't too
much of a truck trouble but it was very
close and things could have easily gone
in the opposite direction one of the
ways in which it was closed was that
there were just very close votes
Massachusetts was 187 to 168 New
Hampshire was 57 47 New York was 30 27
so very close votes involved you know a
couple of people changing their mind and
that would have meant various states
didn't ratify in addition to that some
of the states actually did not ratify so
the first thing that happened was Rhode
Island early on in the process says we
don't like your your horrible
Constitution they all expected that
we're not going to hold even a
convention you want us to hold the
convention we're not gonna hold a
convention we're just gonna have a vote
in state and that vote in the state 90%
of the people voted against the
Constitution so in a way Rhode Island
actually voted against ratification
although it didn't use the proper method
North Carolina also they held a
convention and they were very upset
about there not being a bill of rights
in the Constitution and they just didn't
approve it they didn't disapprove it
they just did nothing and they they
waited so in a way two of the states
voted against ratification North
Carolina had not yet ratified when
George Washington took office so in fact
when George Washington took office there
were only 11 states in the Union at the
end of the day crucial people I think
decided it was better to
signed the Constitution and be in on the
ground floor then stay out and see what
happened
interesting so who are some of the major
players involved here and what were they
arguing about there were the Federalists
who were arguing in favor of ratifying
the Constitution and the
anti-federalists who were arguing
against ratifying the Constitution so
the Federalists the two of the very
famous ones are familiar names Alexander
Hamilton and James Madison those two
people though were also particularly
important because they decided Hamilton
said we're gonna have a tough time
getting ratification in New York we need
to write some essays defending the
Constitution and so Hamilton and Madison
cooperated together and wrote what we
now call the Federalist Papers which
were simply essays written in the
newspapers trying to urge the New York
Convention to ratify the Constitution
eventually those essays were sent to
other states and became known and now we
we come to revere those those essays as
the Federalist Papers but they were
originally just kind of advocacy pieces
for ratifying the convention now there
were also anti federalists the
anti-federalists in part was simply
people who opposed the Constitution and
just as it's the case that say people
opposed Obamacare from both the left and
the right people who opposed the
Constitution opposed it for many
different reasons and one of their
problems was they were not a United
Bunch but in general these were people
fearful of a very strong national
government they believe states were
sovereign they wanted to keep power of
local and they were very fearful of what
they perceived to be an elite who would
run the Constitution after ratification
the names that people may know who were
anti federalists were people like
Patrick Henry and Samuel Adams so what
were some of the major arguments made in
favor of adopting this new constitution
there were I think two types of
arguments
people felt that the articles were not
working properly they had all kinds of
problems and one of the strongest
arguments that the Federalist Papers
made was that if we don't fix this and
make for a stronger union together what
will happen is we'll break apart look at
what happens when you have a bunch of
states all next to one another in a land
area we know what that looks like it's
called Europe and what happens in Europe
they fight wars with one another all the
time and those wars are very problematic
you have to have big armies standing
armies now there were also the
particular arguments about what powers
were missing that the federal government
had done the main arguments were made
was the federal government did not have
enough power so they didn't have for
example the taxing power and they didn't
have a way of enforcing treaties against
the states very well and some of the
states were putting tariffs up so
interfering with trade within the
country so states would set tariffs on
out of state goods States wouldn't
contribute to the national government
second we needed to present a united
front to foreign governments so we were
very worried what would happen if South
Carolina formed an alliance with England
and North Carolina formed an alliance
with France that would be good the
country needed to speak with one voice
so those are some of the arguments made
for adopting the Constitution what were
some of the arguments against adopting
this new constitution
well first argument was even though most
anti-federalists admitted the Articles
needed some repair they said it's not
really urgent it's not like the house is
going to fall down tomorrow that just
you know the wind is coming through and
we can figure it out we really want a
better Constitution the other arguments
were the Constitution put too much power
in the national government it put too
much power in elites the fear was if you
had national elections only elites would
win if you had local elections people
the people actually knew would win
so they thought a big national
government would be too far away from
the people to know what they really
needed as opposed to state governments
which they perceived as being sort of
more personal closer to the needs of
individuals so compare two kinds of
Elections first how many people really
know anyone who runs for Senator who
runs for president that you're on a
first-name basis with now compare you're
in a school club chances are when
someone runs for an officer of the
school club you know who they are
another type of argument was if you give
the federal government this power and
even if and the Federalists always
argued that the power was limited that
they were being given to the federal
government and the anti-federalists came
back and says well you say it's limited
but what we know from historical
experience is is that once a governments
in power it tends to seize more power
there's a lot of vague phrases in the
Constitution and the federal government
will use those vague phrases to assert
greater and greater power what were some
of the strategies that the framers used
to entice some of the opponents of a
strong central government to ratify the
Constitution so the first thing that
they did was to try to build up momentum
so they knew there were certain states
which were strongly in favor of
ratification small states sometimes
wanted ratification so the first state
that comes in is Delaware and they vote
3204 the Constitution and a bunch of
early states so let's say the first five
states all vote for ratification by
pretty lopsided margin so that builds up
a kind of momentum all right we have
five states we only need four more of
course the the next ones that we're
going to come we're going to be much
more difficult and they then needed to
change their strategy at that point you
know they argued like crazy the
Federalist Papers are a very famous
example they indicated they Bo
to amendment once the Constitution was
ratified then again in Pennsylvania when
anti-federalists boycotted the
convention and the result is the
convention didn't have a quorum
they ordered the sergeant-at-arms to a
tavern these swords and arms found some
boycotting anti-federalists and
physically put them in the building so
they could count for a quorum doesn't
get told in a hole Wow
the framers could play rough-and-tumble
politics with the best of them a lot of
the things that pop up at the time of
the framing I think we look back on
today and imagine how would this work in
today's era with you know 330 million
Americans do you think the system under
the Articles of Confederation with a
smaller more local government could
possibly work today well among other
things the Articles had no great means
of collecting taxes or gaining revenue
given that modern government needs
trillions of dollars the Articles if
you've got a thousand dollars it was a
miracle so the articles clearly don't
work but the articles were inadequate
for eighteenth-century
government they were clearly inadequate
or would be clearly inadequate for 21st
century government now the Constitution
appears to have been adequate for
eighteenth-century government whether it
is adequate for 21st century government
is a fair question one of the
interesting questions about the
constitution is how democratic is the
Constitution this debate about how
democratic the Constitution is actually
enters into the question about
ratification on one level the
Constitution was democratic because each
state in these ratification conventions
voted on whether to ratify by majority
vote on the other hand at the federal
level the ratification requirement
required 9 out of 13 and the idea there
would be we needed more buy-in we needed
a limitation on simple majority rule in
order to
to make the system function well in
order to produce a a constitution that
would have support from from the whole
country the interesting thing about that
super majority rule and something that
people don't often make the connection
with is we probably owe our bill of
rights to that supermajority rule
because if only 7 of the 13 states that
the mirror majority had been needed to
ratify the Constitution then it's quite
possible that the Federalists wouldn't
have had to promise to put a bill of
rights into the Constitution because
they wouldn't have needed to and they
were initially quite opposed to putting
a bill of rights in the Constitution it
was only the fact that they needed nine
out of the thirteen states that that
really forced their hand and forced them
to promise that they would put the bill
of rights in there so we see the in
terms of the ratification that there's
both sort of Democratic elements but
also Republican or supermajority
elements so we've learned that it wasn't
easy to ratify the Constitution the
framers bypassed state legislatures and
went directly to the people in state
conventions hoping that momentum and
arguments for a stronger federal
government would entice the opponents of
the Constitution to ratify it it took
until 1789 for 9 out of 13 states to
ratify the Constitution and finally make
it law to learn more about article 7
check out the National Constitution
Center's interactive Constitution and
Khan Academy's resources on US
government and politics